a sequencing of moves is so critical you
look at anybody that's winning in life
you know for me a long time ago I
created a 20-20-20 plan and here's what
I meant by the first 20 years as you're
growing up just make sure you don't make
a big mistake and when I say big mistake
just don't get a felony don't get a rat
don't do anything that that's gonna hurt
you for 10 20 years the next 20 years is
find an industry that you can give 20
years to and go make real money I'm not
talking money like 50 grand 100 grand
I'm talking make real money have some
money in the bank have a few million
dollars in the bank if you can get to
the 10 number even better then on your
third 20 you can choose to chase passion
because you have now money so but don't
use the run of you trying to make your
first few million to just chase passion
that's there's so much you know nonsense
about this passions w if you chase your
passion you'll make it you never be a
we're gonna a day in your life okay
great my passion is people but I want to
make movies there's a lot of things I
want to do my life I'm just not going to
do that this face but I'm gonna do it on
the next move I may have some interest
in sports teams or politics or other
things it's not happening during this
segment not during this session those
things are why I wrote this book called
your next five moves when you're done
reading this book you will never look at
your life and your decisions the same
way you'll sit there by yourself and
you're bored out of your mind and you'll
say you know what what's my next move
okay I want to be able to do this what
do I need you to practice okay first you
need to call this guy they need to get
to this they needed this much money they
need this technology they need to
recruit this then we need to get this
software didn't I need to go out and get
this I need to learn this I'm gonna buy
every single book on Amazon on these
three topics how many books are dumping
hey can you order every single book on
these three topics what do you mean any
book with over 300 reviews that's four
star or higher buy all the books okay
great and then imma that's that's the
game you know that's the game so yeah
this challenges the person to think in a
complete different way where you don't
just say let me just read a book cuz
somebody recommended me if people send
me hundreds of books I don't read any
one of them the reason why I don't read
any one or because I'm I'm in charge of
what I want to
study next not the world what do I want
to study next I choose topics then I
devoured those topics not the world says
hey you know go read this book no no
this will make you say no more often
because you know exactly what you want
to you not what the world wants you to
do it challenges people are too often
living somebody else's life listen you
got to go live your life I got three
kids I love these guys but if you think
for a moment I expect them to sell
insurance you're out of your mind
all I look for for these guys is I sit
down I talked and my oldest is very
weird he's right over a hundred books he
just finished his first business book by
the way eight years old and he read it
like this and he he comes in every day
he needs to he finished the documentary
the last dance right now he's greeting
that watching the documentary men who
built America right when you watch this
guy grant if you say the smallest thing
about his character he's offended yours
a grudge you won't forget it he'll
remind you even like any you said this
to me I'm not okay with that
he's very sensitive but he has
boundaries you cannot cross older people
are intimidated by this eight-year-old
kid it's very interesting kid Randy
spent like that for a long time my
middle one I can't say this to him
everyone loves this kid if he's got a bo
Jackson but he's got calves of an
athlete the guy is chiseled like this
girls love him he's a beautiful writer
you know big heart
competitive protect his sister so gentle
with her you know very interesting guy
charismatic charming you know
interesting taste for music full of life
wants to be around people never wants to
be alone just going on he comes to the
office walks or goes in people's offices
and just talks um so what are you
working on today he's six years old I
mean what are you working on today my
ocular would never do that
my youngest I surprised her the other
day and I said baby I'm gonna take you
out on your birthday we're gonna go on a
date night me and you are going on a
date us can I go to mommy we're going on
mommy daddy's taking me on a date I mean
she can't hold yourself back with
enthusiasm right I can't wait to see
Brad what moves them I can't wait to see
what industry moves them once I know
what moves them
it's the gamer plane I saw there's to it
not the game that Maddie wants to play
the game they want to play and we're
gonna put the next 15 25 moves for them
not for their daddy that's how I lead
people that's how I build people and
that's how I identify my next moves on a
next vision or goal I'm chasing so I
would say this book yes I'm gonna say
you're an x5 applause folks you heard it
you go get it at your next five move
comm you want to follow Patrick at
Patrick bet David you're probably
already subscribed value tainment on
youtube if you're not you'd be crazy if
you don't get there before you even
freaking finish this podcast Patrick I
appreciate your time today you're a
gentleman and a scholar and as always
man if you guys think someone should
hear this go out share it and make sure
that you always keep it real thanks
Patrick I appreciate your time today
thanks buddy preciate you
[Music]